something's wrong with our galaxy
they're not enough stars the Milky Way
is made up of more than 200 billion
stars arranged in a flat spiral but
there should be more up there a lot more
one of the things that's hard to
understand about the Milky Way is why
there are actually so few stars our
Milky Way should have 10 times as many
stars as it does but it doesn't one of
the big questions is why according to
the rules of old-fashioned physics the
Milky Way should be bigger because it's
surrounded by colossal clouds of gas and
dust the building blocks of new stars
over billions of years the vast gravity
of the Milky Way should have sucked
these clouds inside its boundaries
but cosmologists now think
magnetic fields are interfering with
star formation there's a huge amount of
gas that comes way from outside the
galaxy that wants to fall in and then be
available for star formation what
prevents all of that gas and dust that
we know is out there from turning into
stars it might just be magnetic fields
so how did magnetism stop the Milky Way
from getting fat ten billion years ago
the fledgling Milky Way is nothing more
than a vast ball of stars but over time
spin flattens the ball into a disc the
disc grows as its vast gravity sucks in
more and more stars
gravity is ultimately first responsible
for the collapse of matter which form
galaxies once matter begins to move and
interact magnetic fields become
important early supernova shockwaves
create turbulence spreading magnetic
fields into the infant Milky Way disc as
the disc spins these magnetic lines
weave a protective cloak around the
young galaxies here's the problem in our
galaxy it's such a tangled web of
magnetic field lines and this magnetism
can prevent stuff from falling in on the
center of the galaxy this web has messed
up star formation in the Milky Way
magnetic fields played a fundamental
role in keeping that gas out this puts
the brakes on star formation and keeps
new stars from forming as fast as we
think they would in the Milky Way
magnetic fields surrounding the Milky
Way stop gas from falling in and forming
new stars